[Applause]
it's bedlam here in cleveland
curry blocked by james
lebron trying to get to the rim little
fall back off the glass
look out below like a jet coming down
the runway
just took off cocked it all the way back
jordan pool a couple of years in
michigan oh great pass
and the finish by kuzman he appreciated
that
unbelievable dish there's a sunday
opening for lebron you see that pass
right on the money look at this thing
catch lay it up and in
lebron james five to shoot he pokes it
away
james up and under throws it off the
backboard oh and a perfect pass
to himself yeah mike
how about this play by lebron james
great recognition
great awareness and tremendous god-given
ability
three games of these finals he's got to
play better
turns it over james keeps his dribble
somehow irving back to change
oh he throws it down so this looked like
it was going to be a
toss-up pass out of bounds lebron james
still has the athletic ability
catches and throws it down
mama there goes that man that's a long
distance
alley-oop slam
[Applause]
get caught up but julia's very upset
james drives scoop left pass to himself
and he throws it down
he went up in the air and had nowhere to
go james in transition
caught in the air nothing else to do
throws it off the backboard
no reason to get to the finals and turn
it down barnes
as moscot throws it down no
a pass from lebron james he's going
crazy
how about the vision of lebron james
already aware of the fact that bob's dog
was wide open
does not look little magic johnson in
the finals
mazda does the rest
[Music]
[Applause]
lebron james taking two guys and
finishing
at the rip my goodness mama
there goes that man drives on james
finds mcgee
mcgee looking to post up stolen by james
james drives hard and throws it down
a steal an attack
and a massive throw down i love the
attack one on one this is kd versus
lebron james
he tells javel mcgee mind your business
it's bedlam here in cleveland
[Applause]
curry blocked by james
making a statement on both sides of the
floor says to the two-time mvp
get it out of here not on my watch hop
step inside blows it up
misses rebound taken by iguodala
bring a dollar to curry back to iguodala
up for the layup oh blocked by
james lebron james with a rejection
wow great pass by curry
running hard by iguodala
and superhuman defensive recovery
by lebron james
what up it's your boy adam lefkow do you
like that content i know you like that
content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report